train de se jouer sur le terrain on
retrouvera aussi clovis casali à kiev
qui avoue un couvre feu a été
décrété par le maire de la ville ont
fait signer clovis est avec nous clovis
bonsoir la nuit et vous me corrigez
sûrement tour mais assure qu'ils avaient
il ya eu cet appel du maire de la ville
tout à l'heure à la population sous
couvre-feu instauré lui demande aux
ukrainiens de ne pas céder à la panique
des videmment rester chez eux on sent
bien il ya un vrai moment de fred
fébrilité et un du côté de la capitale
ukrainienne beaucoup d'ailleurs ce matin
et ont décidé de partir ils ont
peut-être renoncer au vu de ces longues
files d'attentes sur la route 1 et
devant les stations service aux siens
à la nuit est tombée la plus aussi ici à
kiev place maïdan une journée historique
forcément pour l'histoire de l'ukraine
et dans le mauvais sens du terme vous
l'aurez compris de nombreux ukrainiens
de nombreux habitants de la capitale qui
ont fui qui ont fui par peur des combats
par peur de l'arrivée des troupes russes
ici le maire de la ville a donc décrété
annoncé un couvre feu c'est très très
calme ici ça a été très calme toute la
journée les gens qui restent à l'abri on
a entendu des sirènes vont retentir
plusieurs fois dans la journée et aussi
des explosions surtout cette matinée
durant la matinée mais aussi un petit
peu cet après-midi et des sirènes des
ambulances des forces de sécurité
déployés un peu partout dans la capitale
des blindés mais aussi quelques chars le
pouvoir ukrainien qui prend les choses
bien sûr très au sérieux qui voit cette
attaque russe cette invasion opérer un
petit peu partout dans le pays et il y a
notamment d'intenses combats selon la
présidence ukrainienne
tout près de kiev à un aéroport
militaires est aussi un peu partout
autour il y a eu des attaques et
forcément des blessés sont les
ukrainiens ils ont réussi à repousser
les russes les ukrainiens qui disent
combattre farouchement et le président
zelensky qui appelle les ukrainiens à
prendre les armes tous les ukrainiens
prêt à défendre la nation sont invités à
prendre les armes et kiev qui déclare qu
ils leur donneront
les armes nécessaires pour se défendre
ici à kiev je peux vous dire très très
calme les restaurants les bars les
commerces tous fermés aujourd'hui s'il
n'était pas déjà ce matin ils ont baissé
rideau durant la journée et ce soir même
de nombreux hôtels demandent à leurs
clients d'évacuer si ce n'est ce soir
demain matin à l'aube beaucoup de gens
ici à craignent une invasion ou au moins
des opérations russes dans les toutes
prochaines heures des opérations russes
qu'ils traînent frisant la capitale kiev
un mot peut être clos vinicio ne sais
pas si vous avez des informations
on nous indique que des il y avait des
combats au niveau d'un d'une base
militaire dans la capitale on nous
indique que des forces se re sont
déployés là-bas des parachutistes sur
l'aéroport
de reus thomel près de kiev quant aux
rôles et les forces russes sont en train
de prendre position de se déployant nous
parlait aussi d'hélicoptères et de et
d'avions de chasse
alors on sait que des hélicoptères
russes selon la présidence ukrainienne
auraient survolé aurait tenté d'attaquer
à sept bases militaires tout près de
kiev il y à une riposte des ukrainiens
selon la présidence ici à kiev bien
évidemment alors je peux pas vous
confirmer que des troupes au sol vont
arriver ni les informations que vous
annonciez à tout à l'heure ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que la crainte est
réel ici la population a peur d'une
seule chose c'est l'arrivée des troupes
russes ici à kiev quelque chose
d'inimaginable encore ces dernières
heures déjà ce matin on parle avec les
ukrainiens qui nous disait y at-il
vraiment la guerre on peut pas le croire
ce n'est pas possible vladimir poutine
n'a pas ordonné ces opérations ce n'est
pas possible il n'a pas attaqué
l'ukraine mais force est de constater
que c'est le cas et tout au tout au
cours de la journée et bien au fur et à
mesure des heures les ukrainiens se sont
rendu compte et donc ils se sont
mobilisés
certains ont fui on a vu en était à des
stations essence tout à l'heure on a vu
des files qui s'étendait sur 200 300
mètres et de manière continue toute la
journée des gens prêts à attendre une
heure pour obtenir de l'essence pour
acheter de l'essence
des autorités des gens dans le milieu
pétrolier nous disait aussi que c'était
très compliqué pour l'ukraine parce
qu'aujourd'hui willy à de l'essence mais
demain qui sait car il ya notamment de
l'essence qui doit arriver du bélarus
les frontières sont bloqués les sources
d'approvisionnement se tarissent avec
les combats dans différentes parties du
pays donc très compliqué les gens ont un
petit peu céder à la panique il faut le
dire c'est un calme très précaire ici
une ambiance tendue et en même temps des
gens qui panique qui quittent kiev pour
certains d'autres qui se réfugient dont
le métro juste derrière maidan où je me
trouve dans les souterrains au moment dé
des sirènes et aussi des gens qui
restent chez eux ça a été l'appel du
président ukrainien le maire de kiev qui
a donc décrété ce couvre-feu et le
président ukrainien qui annonce aussi
selon la présidence ukrainienne et bien
que des russes des forces russes ont
essayé de prendre la base de tchernobyl
lusine de tchernobyl et qu' ils ont été
repoussés pour l'instant par des
ukrainiens beaucoup d'informations
difficile à confirmer mais en tout cas
les combats sont intenses entre les
ukrainiens et les russes dans
différentes parties du pays une dernière
question rapidement clovis ans va
retrouver julien chez id azza porridge
ya plus à l'est
non ddd des combats une dernière
question sur ces cesu craignant cette
population qu'on a vu s'entraîner ces
derniers jours des femmes des jeunes des
comptables des notaires enfin d'aider
des profils qui sont pas du tout
aguerris habitué aux combats les
ukrainiens ils sont prêts ils sont prêts
à prendre les armes a à défendre leur
pays aujourd'hui
certains ukrainien certains réservistes
sont habitués aux combats mais face à la
grande armée russe est forcément très
compliqué il faut savoir quand même que
l'ukraine et la partie est et en conflit
ouvert avec la russie depuis de
nombreuses années depuis 2014 alors
c'est vrai les réservistes sont
mobilisés c'était aussi le but de l'état
d'urgence décrété par le parlement et
votée hier donc ses réservistes prêt à
partir au front ou prêts à être
mobilisés pour aider l'ukraine d'une
manière ou d'une autre on a rencontré
dans les rues de kiev aujourd'hui
notamment des forces de ces des membres
des forces volontaire de kiev ceux qui
sont susceptibles susceptibles d'être
appelés par leur commandant pour aller
combattre ou pour défendre leur ville
défendre la capitale c'était le message
du président qui les appeler à prendre
les armes alors est-ce que c'est
l'ukrainien sont prêts à se battre c'est
véritablement la question certains
forcément certains sont prêts en tout
cas il y à un véritable sentiment
d'abandon aussi vis-à-vis de l'ouest de
l'occident beaucoup de gens ici ne
comprennent pas pourquoi les états unis
pourquoi d'autres nations ne sont pas
intervenus plus tôt pour empêcher
vladimir poutine d'envahir de mener ces
opérations coordonnées de grande
envergure contre l'ukraine il ya aussi
un effort de guerre avec de nombreux
ukrainiens qui donne qui donne de
l'argent qui donnent des vêtements à des
ong pour ensuite être distribués aux
troupes placées au front et qui sont en
train de combattre la russie en tout cas
je peux vous dire que l'atmosphère est
très très particulière machiavel l'a été
toute la journée entre panique situation
voilà les ont coupé avec clovis casali
re merci à vous clovis évidemment un
mobilisent